Good morning, good morning
everyone. I want to start this presentation by
thanking the organizers of
this live videoconference for the
Spanish tracking initiative that
allows all
Spanish-speaking professionals
to participate in an event that is
undoubtedly renowned.
I want to start  the presentation with a
very brief overview of what it is to
invent the institution where I work
the mere state is 52 years old
at this moment it has 61
master's and doctoral programs
653 scientists of which 20
percent are
researchers who have
approved protocols for the care and use of
animals works in four major areas
engineering sciences exact
and natural sciences social
sciences and multidisciplinary programs and
biological and health sciences cinvestav
has agreements with 25 countries and
students from 40 countries participate in
its postgraduate courses  we have 9 campuses throughout
the republic it
is really a  institution that today
occupies the second place in
scientific production in the country and number 11 in
Latin America'
with this introduction now I introduce myself I
am Jorge Fernández
the director of the animal life
of this institution for 20 years and it
is a pleasure to be able
to put you  to you the
characteristics and the design of the
new facilities that in a short time
we are going to inaugurate
the content of our presentation
some generalities then will come the
characteristics and the design in a
general sense and the benefits that it brings to
all of us who work with laboratory animals
in the cinvestav and therefore to the
investigation
our new facilities are indigenous to the
project as a whole
this is a project of 2600 square meters
that has two fundamental areas the
small rodents unit where we
consider the rats the
hamster mice the mongolian verbs
in  general sense and a second unit
that is yet to be built  already designed
environment to build where we are going to
have the rest of the species
made up of rabbits, horses or
whose etc.
the fundamental objective of this unit
is to produce and maintain rats,
mice and other small rodents with the
required quality that goes without saying
that  It is something very important for the
development of scientific research
in any place,
the above in the best
housing conditions, management with
environmental enrichment techniques for the care and
welfare of the animals according to
the particular characteristics of each
route, a model in question
and therefore  course something that should not be
forgotten in the best conditions
for workers in a
clean environment occasionally also
considered ultra clean with the use of
personal protective equipment and with a
high level of occupational safety in order
to achieve maximum productivity
among non-profit personnel  only that he
works and takes care of the animals but
The student, the technician and the
researcher
are also there. The installed capacity that
we are going to have is 6,000
microisolators. 99% of the animals
will be housed in
high-density ventilator systems,
which together cover an approximate very
close to the  6,000 micro isolators that
on average
already know that approximately 25,600 rodents will be housed in
dependencies that were the size of the weight of
the animals and the species,
a much higher number
than today we have
an annual production of
laboratory animals that should be  around
between 35 and 50 thousand suppliers
that correspond to the 65 different
colonies of which 80% are
immunodeficient transgenic bio models
in the world severely deficient knockout in
no ping
that
is a great responsibility that
we have with him
the great
of d
models or of different biomodels
particularly between
this is a very unique slide
Right now, in the
facilities that we have today, we
have an area of ​​3,000
square meters. We have an average of
3,3500 boxes where rodents are housed,
and we have approximately
14,200 rodents housed in
the conditions that we are going to have in the
near future.
It will be in an area that is half the size
of the current one with double the number of micro-
insulators and with
practically double the possibility
of rodent accommodation, this is
basically due to the technology
that we decided to acquire, to the technology
that we associate with the building.  and the
characteristics of the same which
we will go to shortly
this is a slide where we are
showing the first level the first of
the three levels
the first level is made up of
a clean room a clean room with
flexible walls it is commonly
known as a bubble it is a  clean room
where we are going to house
and all the genetically modified rodents
and the lava area will be  do
disinfection and sterilization as well as
the administrative part the offices and
the area where the delivery and
reception of animals will be the building has
its main entrance through this
area here to the left to the left
of this area are the corridors that
take you later  When
transferring to the bathrooms where
men and women will be and
later, once the
barriers have been crossed, once two air fights have been crossed,
the staff dresses in their
personal protective equipment and
immediately
accesses the bubble or room to the
clean room of the  What we will talk about in
this clean room is made up of
eight ventilated racks, more or less, for
about 6,000 animals.
This is the area where
the animals will be dispatched. This will be a
small quarantine area for
animals that are imported from
commercial companies or from  other institutions
with which we have collaboration
this is the administrative area and this is
a very important  e area the
washing area and the disinfection area this
area of ​​the disinfection valley is
made up of a tunnel washer
that is shown here in the drawing
a tunnel washer that does its
complete process of what you are
discarding the so-called  dirty until
the other side of the barrier ends, a
barrier that is formed by this area
until the drying process
of types of bedding placement ends and in
that case the micro insulator the micro
insulator box is ready to be
prepared and later  sterilized,
there is also a rap washer
that gives us the capacity to
wash and disinfect everything that is
capable of the possible equipment that is placed
in the washing racks and these two
teams serve as a boat for each other if
it serves as an alternative  When faced with the
need for maintenance, repair
or even
one equipment does not work, we have the
other to replace
this is one is one
is a characteristic of the entire
i  nstallation and we will talk about it
later in this area here
we have the autoclaves a
large autoclave that is called the autoclave
and an autoclave of medium
medium capacity both autoclaves also one
serves as a burton of another and allows us to
maintain the conditions the demands
of the procedures in this case
of sterilization and guarantee of the good
result of this process
this is in general terms
the first level on all levels of the
building consists of three levels on
all levels there are controlled accesses
the main entrance and only entrance
where the staff have to register
their fingerprint, enter a code and at
the same time pass a card, the
fingerprint is primary for everyone and the
card or the code will be an alternative
so that
the fingerprint and one of the three options
must match  the other two but the personnel do not
pass and will only go to the
personal installation that has a protocol  or
then there are other
physical barriers such as doors that also
have access depending on the
place where it is incorporated,
we go to the second level the second
level has a very
similar configuration to the first, without the
service areas without the disposal areas
bedridden and dirty equipment and
so all these all this level
is formed by
bubbles all independent of
others and by all these indicators the
level where we are going to produce the
rats and the other living models
is a characteristic has been
characteristics of the cinvestav in the
last 20 years and producing fewer
rats and more mice but even so the
demand for
since the use of rats is still
great and it is considered to maintain it
in this proportion there are few
lines few strains of rats
unlike mice that are many strains of
rats but the smallest
each of these rooms will house in
particular a colony
in the fan systems
q  That I will explain to you later and
that they are going to allow, well, the
production that I was telling you about up to 50,000
animals in one,
the access is done in the same way through the
first level. When you reach the first
level, you have access to a ladder that
It allows you to go up to this second level to
join the corridor
towards the locker area towards the
changing room area
with two showers, two intermediate air showers
that not only allow you to make
the correct use of
personal protective equipment but also
microbiologically delimit the areas not
controlled as the external corridors
against correspondence with the internal areas
and once the personnel enters
through the use of the pp they are already incorporated
into the bubble to which their
work corresponds in it
and you already know that here it is
also done with  entry procedures of
not accessing
different colonies without first also
carrying out some procedures for
changing clothes
we go to
the  third level the third level is the
level where the animals
that are already part of an
experimental protocol are going to be housed and that
consequently their
housing conditions in some cases are very
different their conditions the
experimental procedures in one
way or another
affect  the animals and therefore
the best conditions must be maintained also
the movements of animals that leave
the production areas to the
research areas are done
by means of a forklift
exclusively for the animals and in
this case the equipment  dirty clean equipment
that also moves between
levels is done by a forklift
called dirty in the case of
dirty equipment and I mean this forklift and
the clean equipment forklift and I
mean this other forklift all
that is clean goes up  this forklift
everything that is dirty goes down these
forklifts and the process that everyone
is u  The unit has a characteristic of
having 566 bubbles and clean rooms,
already called bubbles,
where
the protocols whose
characteristics are compatible are going to be housed, one
like
all in ventilated systems, all
workers
with one
with really unbeatable environmental conditions in
this area that we see here.  It is an area
with the standard design the
well-known design the already
widely used design of the rooms with
rigid walls with epoxy floors with,
well, floors, walls and epoxy ceilings
with air injections and extractions at
room level 15-20 air changes
per  time and what we all know because
because in this area
those protocols that have to be
carried out with supplier animals are going to be accommodated,
basically where the use of the micro
isolator is made difficult by the
characteristics of
the two that have to do with
and electrophysiology protocols  that
have to do with the wii
with some studies
on the d cycle  e light-darkness is inverted
here we also have the area this is the
room destined for aquatic species
where we will also have fish turtles
the calls to possible etc. if you are
a room with
somewhat regular characteristics of
very normal characteristics that we know in the
usual designs  Unlike the
rest of the installation, this in general terms is
these,
on this slide I show in this
circle
I am showing that here we will have a
bubble
with a biosafety level of
biosafety number 2 for those
protocols that need to be highlighted,
in this case this bubble will have
its conditions, let's say the reverse of
what it is, conditions of containment of the
pathogen that is working
at biosafety level 2,
these bubbles, these equipments
also allow us when necessary and
if possible, convert them into
positive pressure in such a way that it
becomes  in a bubble where they are
kept  animals free of
specific pathogenic germs or go back to
work again with the level where
biosecurity are the characteristics and
the flexibility that
this one has this technology
this is an area this photo is not the photo
of our facility this is yet to be
done but it is to give  an idea of ​​how they
will be, the closest thing we have been able to
find to the boxes of what the
so-called bubbles will be
like, as you can see, they are equipment
with flexible walls with plastic ducts, motor
steering, in a moment we are going to review
their anatomy and more or less this will be the
characteristics of our
facilities
the clean room the clean room is a
room that allows you to have air
classes
without a doubt that has already been demonstrated
it is not the characteristic of the air that
we are going to have once we have
housed the mice but
microbiologically speaking it is a
installation is a room where you
have the best conditions
in terms of the environment of the
animals
and its operation is very simple, it is
relatively easy,
the bubble has a door, it can be
a rigid door, it can be a
Hawaiian-type door, that is,
it allows us to access without any
restriction, it has its motors, it has
HEPA filters, and it has
flexible air ducts.  intake
of the area where an air is housed
that is already, let's say, with the temperature and
with the necessary humidity required for
the models in question in the air,
passes it through a type e filter to
inject a plenum into its
interior in the  The bottom parts are like
a roof that has a bubble where
at the bottom it has thousands of
holes that make the vertical air flow
from top to bottom and be of
the laminar type. This
air covers all the racks, all the
equipment.  all the
material inside the bubble comes back
out and is filtered again this is a
non-stop non-stop process it does not stop
unless there is a  failure in an engine we
already have the experience for 6 years of
having systems with this technology
where the engine has not failed for a single
minute it is a very
affordable technology very easy very
very I adore with times of scarcity
let's say financial filtered air  At
100%
, about 80 or 100 air changes per hour are generated,
but the laminar flow does not generate
turbulence, so it is an air, it is an
area where animals
can be kept without a doubt
in the best possible conditions.
The installation as a whole has 12
clean rooms of these so-called
bubbles two rooms of the
biosecurity level those that can be
positive negative and with
serious principles to positive seven air showers
are located in the different accesses
3 2 on each level to access the
facilities where the animals are housed
and  one to access the
clean area for washing and disinfection and
7 pass-through transfers, that is, 7 also
called those that are located in
let's say where the dirty equipment comes out on the
first level the dirty equipment towards asia
the equipment from the clean zone the
dirty equipment from the clean zone towards the area of
the non-flexing band there is one located
in front of each forklift
because the forklifts are
working
in the juice, let's say, makes the
piston effect and I repeat, moves air that
is not controlled, however, this
transfer located in front of
each of the forklifts
allows us to take that dirty air and
convert it into clean air, all of
this is a  Example of the air shower
that will be placed at the different
access points to the facilities where
the staff will use their
personal protective equipment,
which consists of everything from hats
to face masks, some may be
95 others will be face masks or  the
standard face masks of your gown and
your beloved tops
this is this changing room process the
staff will do it at the time they are going to
enter
this is this is  a sample photo of a
biosafety level 2 bubble
for work with infectious pathogens in
another facility that is not
ours but I show it as a way
for them to understand that they can
appreciate that
the person has access to us here when  is going to access and in this
case all the air filtration equipment for
air intake motors
hepa filters and ducts are
inside the facility
within the characteristics of the
procedures of the
work processes we are going to have well they are already
acquired  just discard the
racks and shelves for transport transfer of
dirty equipment from clean equipment from the
different levels to the
washing areas or once washed and sterilized
to the different floors they will be
differentiated by their cover the
blue cover corresponds to clean equipment and
prepared ready to be used and the
red cover corresponds to equipment that
has to be in the
disinfection process washes  done and even in some
cases this previous realization before
the washing and disinfection process
these are also samples here we are
showing
transfer or
the transfer steps that are located
in the critical points where it must be
controlled
sanitaryly speaking in Indian areas
in this case it is an area  where
the dirty bedding is worked and disposed of and in the
possible way to the bottom of the bottom in this
is the case where the equipment is being removed
from a clean area that crosses through this
zone by this transfer and here it is processed
and then passed  once again
into the barrier and
once washed disinfected is also incorporated into the sterilization area
all these photos correspond to
facilities that are not ours but
that are similar to the ones
we took these well
this is the example
of a bubble
in all its extension where the
animals are housed in ventilated systems
in this case if they are appreciated like this they have
a
minimum double double d  obble in protection
in this case because those
with 2
experimental areas are considered
and because they are protocols
with strict control, it was
also decided that each bubble of the
experimental areas where animals are housed
under approved protocols also
access is controlled by a
code an access code independently of
the other three that I already mentioned I
have a question here but
I would prefer to leave it to the end
because you may also be interested in
the experimentation area as I
mentioned in the area in the part of the
area that are the  rooms with the
standard design of walls, epoxy floors, cost
is due to the special conditions that
the room unit cycle said, some
electrophysiology protocols, etc., etc.
where the equipment does not allow, in this
case, the workers and the equipment and
the ventilated systems do not allow
adapting to the requirements  of the
protocol and special equipment is required
then these rooms can  they
are the best known by all and
also good to also access
this room to this area it is also required to
have electronic access
this is a model of the rack
for fish we are going to brand new for fish
we do not have previous experience we are going to
start it now
and  we are going to work on this
a kind of small fish that
we work here in the simple being it is not
the saw
in that same room we are going to have
possible turtles
the accommodation in general we are going to have
these
these ventilated systems and these
changing stations we are going to detail
now  25 one cage
model of equipment that allows us to accommodate
several species in a single rack if
necessary 5 superman 2 750 12 his beard
2800 allow us to work with petty cash
large houses 18 super 1400
also allow us to overcome
other small species such as  The
hamster kept 10 change stations
and 36 alert systems. This is a
novelty of which we
are excited because in this  In this sense,
the alert systems housed in
each of the racks will allow us to
know the temperature standard,
basically, to know the problems that
can arise in each
of the racks, wherever you
are, you will know about it and  We are going to
talk about that now
we are going to have the 27 one cage these 27
one cages well we are going to have these
maximum capacities to touch animals
it will not really be like that but this is the
capacity that it gives us and we can do it
regardless of the possibilities or
the  characteristics that will
generate the demand for laboratory animals
in the case of your karma 27 50, which is
all made up of small boxes
of 750 square centimeters,
since it allows us to house up to
1900 mice equal to or less than 10 grams,
in general they must be
that  The same happens with the 1800 in
which we are going to have 10
and of the super 2400 we are going to have 9 in
total we are going to have approximately
50 back ventilated between  Of the 36 that we have already
acquired and the 14 that we have
today that also allow us to be
transferred to the new facilities,
we are going to have several change stations,
some of which are the type
of change stations that work with
those with bubbles.
change stations that are allowed to be
attached to a window of each bubble and
can be transferred from bubble to
bubble according to the needs
of the work
we can work with a
change station in several bubbles with
well-organized work and we have the stations
of traditional changes
of very good quality and of a dimension
of 1.8 meters 6 feet that allows us to
work with quite large boxes,
you can get bigger and workers with
I told them that we are going to put 36
alert systems that are going to be placed in
each of the  ventilated systems this
allows us to know any problem
that arises with the microenvironmental
parameters in any  We
are going
to receive
the emails of the people who
join the system, of course,
the technicians in charge of the areas
will also be the personnel
responsible for maintenance of
any alteration that  there is with
respect to electrical energy with
respect to the temperature with respect
to the filters that are already saturated with
respect to what is necessary
in this way let's say that
I can say that we could sleep
peacefully as long as the alarms do not reach us
we are also going to have
a  box for each of the shelves
that it monitors, records and transfers the
information of the microenvironment of
in the 3rd case of each rack in terms of
temperature, time and date of the
information and location of the
fan shelf that also allows us to
know what problems this may have
information all asia stores and is
transferred to a computer that we will
allocate for him
and is also monitored  Also remotely
the real time while self-
calibrating each moment even with the
rodents housed in the
past we had to request
services in this regard so that a
technician would come
from abroad and not do the job and
that did not generate a high cost
now we can avoid we save
those expenses that are necessary
to maintain a standard and comply
with a calibration procedure by
acquiring this type of technology
each ventilated shelf because it has
its controls in this case it has two
injection fans two where
extraction in  each one of them can
know
the pressure if it is positive negative if it
is not so an alarm is generated the
average temperature in each one
of the boxes
in the micro insulators the state of the
pre-filter the hours worked etc.
etc. in
addition to this that  We have talked
and we see that there is a lot of
information about it and it gives us a lot of information in that
sense.  information on what is
happening and the guarantee that the
animals are in an adequate environment and
well-being, we will also
locate them at each level and in
a mobile
way we will rotate the so-called data
loggers that allow us to monitor
temperature as well.  not only the rack
but also the room or the bubble
where they are housed and also the macro
environment of the floor where
the bubbles and micro insulators
and humidity are housed and above all also something
that is important to know about the intensity
of light in the space  where this form is placed we
also monitor that and at
the same time we monitor that
the light or dark cycle is working correctly and there are no
mechanical problems that affect us and
that really do not allow us to be
alert in this sense
this is one of the characteristics of
this installation and  something also
new is the integration of the
direct connection of each of the
racks to the extraction system  central
this is
is a diagram that shows the bubble is
this zone
let's say this angular zone
here you can see
the rack installed inside the bubble you
can see the bubble in its entirety
and
the extractor or the extraction motor
of the ventilated system connected to the
extraction abductor  of the central system
in this way
many advantages are generated
that allow us to say that the
concentrations of ammonia and co2 in
each of the cages immediately
go outside they do not go to the room they
do not go to the macro environment as it happens
or does not happen  In many cases, and in this
way, in this sense, the concentrations
of
these harmful gases in
concentrations above normal do not affect the
animals
and it really is something that will allow us to
have a better standard.
This is the sample from the camper, like this.
It is called the camper connected to the
roof and the hose of how
the extraction system is connected to the extraction system
of each  rack how it connects to
the camper which in turn is connected to
the extraction
system the system behind the central ventilation system
yesterday i saw some talks they were
talking
about barriers they were talking about
the security system well this is a
this is something like  a way of
understanding how our barriers are,
both sanitary and physical
physical security barriers
biological security barriers that are formed
first by the building and then by
the work area or the floor each of
the levels
then the clean room and then the  finishing the
micro is work where the animals are housed
in this way there are several
levels of protection not only
biological but also
physical security which at this time is a
very important element we will also have an
area where we are going to keep
the animals let's say  more sensitive an
area of ​​insulators beyond sores
called in my fluids and the
gene bank the gene bank  In the
main neighborhoods, the
central ventilation system is made
up of,
we don't know, it is the typical
air injection system, air extraction,
electrical resistors for
heating,
humidifiers, this is controlled
by a whole system that is called the
Hong Kong web station and that  allows us
automatic control of all
parameters allows us automatic action
from all equipment without the
need for human intervention
except for equipment calibration and
maintenance allows us to
record allows us to save all
details of temperature humidity
the intensity of  light to the case
in cycles and allows us to demonstrate the
conditions in which the animals are kept
either for verifications they are
national or even
international certifications the equipment
these are photos of the real equipment they
maintain control 24 hours 7 times 7
days a week temperature more less
2 degrees from 21 humidity  From
30 to 70 positive negative impressions
where necessary
in all cases the systems I
said before have a boat
and there are two pieces of equipment for each
application so that if one
breaks down or if one requires
maintenance the other covers that
need for everything  This system is also
monitored via the web
and through the use of smartphones,
the alarms reach these
phones via message or
email in such a way that all those
who have some responsibility in
this regard are immediately
adapted to the moment of the event,
there is a closed circuit of  television
there are about 20 cameras that have to do
with the security of the personnel with the
security of the use of
personal protective equipment and good for the
physical security
of the installation
the access I already commented
on the access to the building the access to the
different areas everything to  through
programming and recording software
smoke detection system  or and system
of motors or fire pumps
something that is
a law
in the facilities here in our country
these are photos of the washers these and
are real photos of the
washers the tunnel washer the rack washer
that allows us a really process
fast and efficient and also equipment
that allows savings and savings
the lava from
the autoclaves the large autoclave the
autonomous small one also with
energy and water saving systems as well as
steam consumption we go to work
and this is also for
our countries is  a novelty and it is an
experience that we want to be very
good
with the system called europe that
we are going to replace the possible 6,000 bottles
with 6000 bags which should give us
many savings in facilities over
time in
remote personnel etc. etc. etc. is an
experience  of which perhaps in the
near future
we also have in this sense two
teams that allow us to alternate the
ifs  It is necessary or both work at the
same time,
an innovative system for
placing shoe covers
so that we no longer have to bend over
or fall when we
want to put on
shoe covers. They do not have to use benches
in the corridor that can later be
the typical ones in the machine room with
boilers, boilers of 80
horsepower each, which also allow us to
work alternately, compressors
, emergency discharge, forklifts,
a team, a ps, we call 100 ups, it is the
team that allows you to provide continuity and
support  to those elements that are
sensitive such as the control cards
that are used that the
brain system of the ventilation system
computers some
laboratory equipment very sensitive to the peaks
that there may be in current or to the
drop in current and maintains
the levels
afterwards  which these teams have worked
on cinvestav over the years and this was
a slide that was presented to
our director and  n the time we
were trying to convince him of the
need to do this, well, over the
years the number of models has been increasing
today we already have 72 models in
fact we have more than 70 models today and
this has been because it is indicated at this
time it indicated the
urgent need to have better facilities
because the tendency of our
institution is to grow and grow and grow
in the areas of biological sciences
and health, particularly in the areas
of
flights soon
project that work with
laboratory animals that
of all  who work with the
biological and health area more than 90%
work with spirit
this has also been the trend of
protocols approved
today shown here 310 last year
327 2 317 at this time the
trend is also upward and in the
conditions in which we lived
today it was really very difficult to be
able to
guarantee the
welfare requirements and the
scientific requirements.  icos
the number of researchers
has also risen
since 2006, which were 102, today there are
137 already in 2014, in such a way that
the academic staff has improved
and not only has improved but has been
much more perfected
in the use of research animals.  laboratory
and our duty is to give you the answers
to your needs
this is an exterior view
of the building this is real
of the building that I repeat in a matter of a
few
we already started and
the start-up of all of the
technology we started a start-up process
Well, we hope that everything goes well.
I want to thank all the 29
attendees at our presentation for
the time they took to listen to us, and
well, now I can answer the
questions in these ten minutes that
we barely have left
here. There was a question
and they were considered.  Consider the noise that
the bubble motors make
inside the rooms if we have
been working for several years with exactly
seven years working with it.  all the equipment
these equipments do not generate
any noise at all
these equipments their noise is minimal, it is
below 50 decibels and they do not
generate
one of the characteristics of
this installation is that the animals
inside the bubble will be in a
ventilated system inside  a micro
isolator that means that any level of
noise is considered much more
at the level of the microenvironment of the
animals.
I hope I have answered that
question.
They also tell me here thank you very much for
your presentation.
says
when using the bubble I can have the
same room rats and mice the
care of these must be a person
or two
good to use the bubbles the
bubbles of approval what it gives you is an
extremely clean environment and an
environment that is changing
to 80  100 times in a water so that
allows you the best of conditions
and if you have to have rats and mice I
recommend  I would recommend that they were not in
open boxes but that they were at least in
a ventilated system or at home with bree
coleadores so that there is no
interference between a species remember
that the rat is a predator of the mouse and they
should not be
together sharing the microenvironment or
the macro  environment and then the
second one says these bubbles must be
connected to the network and of course they must
be connected to the emergency network
during a cut in use only not in
this case our installation and it is what
I recommend whenever they ask me
a facility for animals  The
laboratory must be connected at 100%
of its capacity to one from an
electrical emergency and, if possible, to a second
electrical emergency network, so
read that scientific institutions
have two lines, two
high-voltage power lines that
reach the institution at
research center the university when
one fails enters another but then the
areas in the sense  In general, they already have their
own emergency plant. In this case,
it works that way.
Thank you very much. Hugs from Chile.
Hugs from Mexico. Also for everyone.
Let's see the other
one.
We are exactly
in the process
of turning the key to energizing the building, giving it
all the necessary energy
and therefore once we
have the energy, which should be in a
matter of a week, two weeks,
then the process begins, the
avalanche of installing equipment already
We will have water and we will have energy and
we can then start the
commissioning of the boilers of the
emergency plant of everything to start
the installation of the
accommodation equipment and bubbles, the central fans. Do
you think that this
bubble technology is good?  for latin america my
personal experience is that yes
my personal experience I have it
I repeat it since h  7 years ago it is a
very economical technology compared to
buildings, let's say buildings of common designs,
I think I have recommended it in several
places and I would recommend it here for
everyone who hears me. I can give you an
example. In 2008 we made an attempt at a
project and  they authorized us to work on
a project the project also generated a
cost and I repeat it was a great project
also for a building of
approximately 2,600 square meters
on three levels but with rigid walls
with all that this entails there were
around 80 rooms for different
uses,
most of them  housing animals other
laboratories and / and this this project
the designers calculated that it had a
cost of 25 million dollars of
course that tuna is an amount
practically impossible to achieve
for most of our institutions
so we gave ourselves to the task  from looking for
options we acquire the way of let's say
knowledge of
training tests this technology  technology and this
technology allowed us to proxy that
this building has a cost of 10
million dollars, of which
only 2 correspond to the
physical structure of the building and 8 venues were left
to technology,
the previous 25 were 13 to the building and
12 to the  technology then that made it
too clear now we were able to reverse
the proportion and we dedicated only 2
million to the building in a building
let's say simple
with housing technology and
control of all possible variables
for animal welfare and to that we
dedicated 8 million
Question
I would like to know if using the micro
isolators as a negative pressure
can house two
different groups of animals with different
pathogens yes as
long as the pathogens
correspond to the level of
insecurity in the conditions where they are
housed is it 1 2 3 4
I am going to spend two at the most so
if they can be as long as they use micro
ice creams and the ca  The characteristic of the micro
insulators that is not shared is the
microenvironment, therefore there is no
interference from this microenvironment
between one box and the other,
between one box and the other, or between my
work or even between ventilated systems, well,
greetings from Mexico
for my Argentine friends.  Here is
another very interesting one and it encourages us and
serves as an experience because that is the dimension.
Even I already said that I thank the
organizers of this event for the
possibility that they give us
Latin American brothers to be able to talk a
little in Spanish this these these these
characteristics these  Technologies that
could only be seen until a
very short time ago and in
English-speaking countries and in highly developed countries,
fortunately
we are already acquiring it, we are going to take it
into consideration in our countries and,
well, besides, I am open
for whatever you like.  whatever can help
you thank you thank you for the compliments
good good you heard me
I still hope I have answered all the
questions they
are answered
yes we almost have a minute left and so much
so let me take advantage of the time of the
minute and so much that I have left to
tell you that this project that we
had spent a long time
working and working on
it last month of  December I also had the
opportunity to practice some of
this
at an international event in Colombia
in Medellin with friends also other
friends from Spain friends from Colombia and from
other countries
Argentina among them as well and I
also talked about not giving up because
these are difficult projects  They
are once in a lifetime projects but they are
projects that are necessary today
for the welfare of animals in the
first place and for the welfare and the
10 achievements of science so it is
something we have to be working on all the
time  and work and work, do not get
discouraged if we fall, get up and
move forward as much as we can
, as much as possible.  Being aware of the
authorities, working a lot with the
ethics committee, is the body that can help us the most,
working with the
researchers, really occupying them as
much time as they can
allocate for this activity, and well,
that is our job, that is
our, our way.  that
we all have to do it anyway is
having to work day by day what
is coming to me is another question
congratulations congratulations well
thank you for this
possibility
I think you are about to put the button on me
thank you very much everyone
I leave